[ELECTRIC CURRENT]
ANNOUNCER: Please
welcome to the stage
the CEO of Google,
Sundar Pichai.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Good
morning, everyone.
It's great to be here.
Thank you all for joining us.
I suppose I should start
out with a confession.
I'm actually not a
big gamer, though I
do play "FIFA '19" quite
a bit and really enjoy
how immersive it is.
I also play "Ashes
Cricket" quite a bit.
And for those of you who are
wondering what cricket is,
it's kind of like
baseball but better.
[LAUGHTER]
Another little known
fact is that Google
makes arguably the most played
game on the internet today.
It's the Dino Chrome
game, mostly played when
there's no internet connection.
I'm not going to talk to
you about the high quality
graphics and sophistication
you all are used to,
but it does have
a lot of players
and I've probably logged more
hours than I care to admit.
While I'm not a big gamer,
I do have the privilege
of working at a
company and leading
a company full of people who
love to solve hard computer
science problems.
For many Googlers, their
journey with computers
started with games.
Games have inspired many
generations of people
to pursue careers in tech.
And through that process,
they build resourcefulness,
creativity, and collaboration.
All qualities that are key
to solving hard problems.
And within Google
and Alphabet, games
play a big part in developing
our own technology.
The best example I
can think of is how
we are making progress on AI.
DeepMind's AlphaZero
uses self-play to learn
from scratch and master games
like chess, shogi, and go.
It's an important
step towards creating
a flexible general
purpose system that
can learn to solve many
foundational problems.
More recently, AlphaStar
became the first AI
to defeat a top professional
player at "StarCraft II."
using a deep neural
network trained directly
from real game data.
Increasingly, games are helping
AIs learn to tackle real world
challenges.
Even beyond DeepMind,
another great example we have
is Waymo, where
we use simulations
in gaming-like
environments to test things
that aren't actually
possible or safe at scale
in the real world.
In fact, Waymo has driven
more than five billion hours
in simulations of
edge case scenarios
that vehicles wouldn't
normally encounter.
And we use it, we learn from
it, and actually improve
the systems that we'll be
deploying in the real world.
Perhaps the biggest
impact of gaming
is how it pushes us to
make big leaps in computing
and networking
power, high fidelity
graphics, and the infrastructure
that supports it all.
All of you are pushing computing
and technology forward,
and I find that really exciting.
At Google, we have
always believed
that technology should adapt
to people, not the other way
around.
We have been building towards
this vision for sometime.
For example, when we
launched Chrome a decade ago,
we imagined, we
envisioned that it
could be a modern platform
for web applications
and bring the power of
web to everyone, including
use cases that seemed
impossible at the time,
like high quality games.
Finally, we are making
progress towards that goal.
In fact, over the past two
years, we've been hard at hard
at work on game
streaming technology.
And last fall, we launched
our first public test
with Project Stream.
As some of you guessed,
a technical test
wasn't the whole
view of our ambition.
It was probably the worst
kept secret in the industry.
Internally, we were
actually testing our ability
to stream high fidelity graphics
over a low latency network.
We learned that we
could bring a AAA game
to any device with
a Chrome browser
and an internet connection
using the best of Google
to create a powerful
game platform.
And when we say
"best of Google,"
it always starts with our cloud
and networking infrastructure.
Our custom server
hardware and data centers
can bring more computing power
to more people on planet Earth
than anyone else.
Today, we are in 19 regions
and in over 200 countries
and territories connected
by hundreds of thousands
of miles of fiber optic cables.
The best of Google, also
includes our open platforms
that allow you to reach
billions of people.
With Google, your games
will be immediately
discoverable by over
2 billion people
on a Chromebook browser,
Chromebooks, Chromecast,
Pixel devices.
And we have plans to
support more browsers
and platforms over time.
That's in addition to all the
people playing and watching
games across YouTube
and Google Play.
And when we build
these ecosystems,
we always take the
approach that we only
succeed when our partners do.
Collectively, our partners
across web, Google Play,
and YouTube have earned more
than $110 billion dollars
over the past four years
alone, and we are committed
to this approach here as well.
So now we have focused
on our next big effort,
which is to build a game
platform for everyone.
And when we say "for
everyone, we really mean it.
It's one of our most
cherished values as a company.
Be it Android, or
Chrome, or AI, we
are dead serious about
making technology
accessible for everyone.
But if you think
about games, there
are a lot of barriers for
users to play high end games.
Beautiful graphics really
need high end consoles or PCs.
And games don't
have instant access.
Think about the
way the web works.
You can easily share a link,
and it works seamlessly.
We want games to
feel that way too,
instantly enjoyable with
access for everyone.
I think we can change the
game by bringing together
the power and creativity
of the entire community--
people who love to play games,
people who love to watch games,
and people who love
to build games.
That means all of you.
We are really excited
to work with you.
We want to build a
platform, and We.
Want you to show
us what's possible.
And together, I think we
can create a new games
experience powered by best of
Google and built for everyone.
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- From the beginning
of time, games
have brought us together,
players and spectators
by the handful, the
hundreds, and the thousands.
We built stadiums,
places to gather around
every kind of spectacle.
Glory, tragedy, pageantry,
community, rivalry, and wonder,
until every city,
town, and village
had a place where
anyone could play.
Thousands of years in,
our games have changed,
but our need to come
together remains.
This new era of gaming
needs a new place to gather.
One place, where anything
you dream can be built,
playgrounds for
every imagination,
one place where you and everyone
you know and everyone they know
will all play together.
- Let's go, let's go, let's go
- Let's go, squad!
- Let's go!
- Yes, get him!
Boom!
[LAUGHTER]
- One place that
never stops evolving,
where everyone will play.
- Where did he come from?
- And watch.
- Yes, high five.
- Bam.
- And create.
- Winner.
- Woo!
- Nice!
From any screen at anytime.
One place for all
the ways we play.
This is Stadia.
Gather round.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI:
Welcome to Stadia.
We are so excited by this.
To do this well, it's important
that we have the right people
working on this, experts with
deep history and heritage
in games.
That starts with Phil Harrison,
who joined us about a year ago.
He's a great leader
and a great gamer.
Definitely someone who
knows the difference
between RPGs and NPCs.
I'm going to pass the mic
over to Phil to show you
what we have built.
Take it away, Phil.
PHIL HARRISON:
Thank you, Sundar.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Hi, Phil.
PHIL HARRISON:
Thank you, Sundar.
It's such a pleasure
to be here today.
And thank you for joining
us at GDC, as we finally
get to share Google's vision
for the future of games,
where the worlds of
watching and playing games
converge into a new
generation game platform
purpose-built for the
21st century, powered
by the best of Google.
Our vision for
Stadia is simple--
one place for all
the ways we play.
It's focused on gamers,
inspired by developers,
and amplified by
YouTube creators.
Today, our industry captivates
over 2 billion players
from all around the world.
At the center of that
community, its beating heart,
are the game
developers, the people
in this room that create
the most incredible game
experiences that delight
players with engrossing stories,
characters, and worlds through a
dazzling display of technology,
artistry, and magic.
Games are now the
single biggest form
of entertainment
on the planet, one
that connects a vast community
across geographies, cultures,
and language.
And within that
passionate community,
there is a universe of people
who love playing games,
and there's a universe of
people who love watching games.
Hundreds of millions of
people watch gaming content
every single day on YouTube.
But those two worlds are mostly
disconnected, fragmented,
and often independent
of each other.
Our vision is to bring those
worlds closer together,
to connect game developers with
players and YouTube creators
in a way that only
Google can, creating
a richer and more vibrant
gaming community for everyone
to enjoy.
Through the power
of our data centers,
the extraordinary reach
and community of YouTube,
and our investments in the
fundamental technologies
that are the foundations
of the open internet,
we offer a truly
unique opportunity
to combine these worlds.
We will be handing that
extraordinary power of the data
center over to you,
the game developers,
where playgrounds for every
imagination can be created.
Our first public test of this
came in October of last year
with Project Stream, where
we streamed a AAA HD game
at up to 1080p and 60 frames
per second over the internet
from Google data centers
to a Chrome browser.
We were humbled by the
overwhelmingly positive
response from players
who were able to join us
on Project Stream.
A huge thank you
to those of you who
participated in Project Stream
and for your vital feedback.
And also to the amazing
people at Ubisoft
for trusting us with
the latest incarnation
of their incredible game
franchise, "Assassin's Creed."
Ubisoft has always been at
the forefront of advancements
in the games industry, and they
have an incredible track record
of success and creativity.
And joining us here
in the audience today,
I'm delighted to welcome the CEO
and co-founder of Ubisoft, Yves
Guilllemot.
Thank you, Yves.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd like to thank
Yves and his team
for partnering with us,
and to producer Marc-Alexis
Cote and the entire
Ubisoft Quebec studio
for their masterpiece creation,
"Assassin's Creed Odyssey."
Thank you for bringing
your game to our platform,
and congratulations for
being the first game
played by the public on Stadia.
As many of you experienced with
"Assassin's Creed Odyssey,"
we now have the ability to take
a sophisticated, graphically
intense AAA game and stream
it to a Chrome browser running
on a simple laptop without
any sacrifice to the quality
or vision of the game developer.
As successful as
Project Stream was,
our ambition is of course
far beyond a single game.
As we developed our strategy
for this new platform,
we asked developers
how we can help
solve some of the most
critical challenges you face.
There were three very clear
themes that resonated.
You told us you wanted to
unleash your creativity
without limits, get to
the widest possible scale,
and make it easier for people
to connect with your games.
We used these three themes
to anchor our vision
and build our
platform architecture,
and began to share it with
the leading publishers
and developers in the world.
Now, let me show you how we have
brought this vision to life.
Imagine you are watching
games on YouTube,
and you discover the latest
"Assassin's Creed Odyssey"
trailer on Ubisoft's
official channel on YouTube.
You will notice the
"Play Now" button.
By simply clicking
on that button,
the player is brought
directly into the game
in a browser in as quick as
five seconds with no download.
[APPLAUSE]
With no download, no patch,
no update, and no install.
Stadia offers instant
access to play.
Our platform vision
for Stadia is
to reduce the friction between
getting excited about a game
and playing a game.
On Stadia, you just need
to click on a YouTube video
or link, and you can be
playing your game instantly.
Compare that to today, where
gamers are all too familiar
with things like this.
With Stadia, this waiting game
will be a thing of the past.
The power of instant
access is magical
and has already transformed
the music and movie industries.
And with Stadia, it is now
available at the highest
level of gaming.
But wouldn't it be
even more magical
if that same game and that
same instant experience
could be available across
any screen type in your life?
A key benefit of our platform
is that a single creative vision
and a single codebase can
now be enjoyed instantly
across any screen.
At launch, we'll support
being able to play games
across desktops, laptops,
TV, tablets, and phones.
This new generation of
gaming is not a box.
With Stadia, the data
center is your platform.
There is no console that limits
the developer's creative ideas,
and no console that limits
where gamers can play.
And we're about to
show this to you now.
This is not a concept.
It's not a test.
This is real.
I'd like to bring my
friend Khaled to the stage
to show you this working.
[APPLAUSE]
So imagine you've
just discovered
that game for the first time.
You're running it on
the Chrome browser.
And here it is on a Pixelbook
running the Chrome OS.
There is basically no hardware
acceleration on that laptop
whatsoever, and the
game is running directly
from our data center.
It's then easy and instantaneous
to move that same game
experience from exactly
that moment onto the phone
here on a pixel 3 XL.
[APPLAUSE]
Once again, no loss
in quality, and we
can go straight
onto the desktop PC.
We actually went to buy the
least powerful PC we could find
here, and we could enjoy the
same vision that the developer
had, the same high quality 1080p
stream at 60 frames per second,
and the full game vision
regardless of the hardware
that you're using.
And then it's, once
again, seamless
to go from running on our
PC to running on a tablet.
In this case, once again,
running the Chrome OS
on a Pixel Slate.
[APPLAUSE]
And then finally, we then
move seamlessly to the TV.
And so this TV is accessed using
this, which is a Chromecast
Ultra HDMI streamer.
There is no console required
to reach this experience.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, Khaled.
Great presentation.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcoming any and all players
is fundamental to Stadia,
where you can try
with your friends
on devices you already own.
And as such, we're
also enabling players
to use your existing
USB controller or mouse
and keyboard when playing
Stadia on a laptop or PC.
By eliminating that friction,
that barrier to entry,
we will make it simple
and easy for players
who want to try Stadia
for the first time.
But of course, we will
have our own controller
that is being uniquely designed
to enhance the experience
for the Stadia player.
I'd like to introduce
you to the newest
member of the Google hardware
family, the Stadia controller.
[APPLAUSE]
This is your gateway
to the best of Stadia.
It enables you to access
the full Stadia experience.
And there are many advantages
to the Stadia controller.
And the first is that it will
connect through Wi-Fi directly
to the game that is running
in the Google data center.
The Stadia controller identifies
which screen or device
you want to play on and links it
with your game session running
in the cloud,
ensuring the highest
possible performance and the
best experience for players.
In addition to the
standard functions
you'd expect to see on a
modern game controller,
the Stadia controller
features two
very important new buttons--
the Capture button is for
sharing and saving your game
experience back out to YouTube.
The gamer can choose to
share their experiences,
starting with the
click on this button,
to themselves, to their
friends, or to the world.
They are in control.
And the second one is the
Google Assistant button.
Pressing this button allows
players to immediately access
the controller's
built-in microphone
so they can get help
from the Assistant
for special in-game features
integrated by developers.
Our goal with Stadia is
to help fuel developer
creativity at every level.
And next, we'll take a look
at the incredible computing
power we have
custom-built into our data
centers that will further
accelerate innovation.
I'd like to introduce
my friend and colleague,
the head of engineering
for Stadia, Majd Bakar.
[APPLAUSE]
MAJD BAKAR: Thanks
so much, Phil.
Let's look at the
real-time computing power
we have put into our
data centers that
will change how we view
what a game platform can be.
In order to deliver an amazing
experience for your games,
we needed to bring powerful
computing closer to users.
We've built Stadia's
architecture
on top of the Google data center
network, the same network that
has been delivering
search results
to your fingertips
in milliseconds
for more than 20 years.
The network consists of
fiber optic links and subsea
cables between hundreds
of points of presence
and more than 7,500 edge node
locations around the globe,
all connected with
our network backbone.
Stadia is built on
an infrastructure
that no one else has.
More edge nodes means
the compute resources
are closer to players, which
results in better performance.
We took that proven
model and infused it
with custom design purpose
built gaming hardware
creating the most powerful
and connected gaming platform.
Each of Stadia's data
centers is composed
of interconnected racks
that deliver the high power
graphics, memory, and
storage needed to run
the most demanding games.
Only with Google can you apply
the power and flexibility
of data centers to
game development.
This architecture
is the foundation
for this new
generation of gaming.
We've been testing this
technology privately
within Google for years.
For our initial public test
with Project Stream in 2018,
we delivered up to 1080p
60 frames per second
with stereo audio.
When Stadia launches, we will
have increased performance
significantly to
support resolutions up
to 4k at 60 frames per second.
[APPLAUSE]
With HDR and surround sound.
And in the future, we'll
be able to stream games
in up to 8k resolution.
[APPLAUSE]
We know there are not
that many homes or TV is
in the world that have
8k today, but we also
know the widespread adoption
of 8k is inevitable.
We have built our
platform to scale up
with the highest
performing networks
to deliver the visual quality
demanded by future generations
of gamers and game developers.
What's even more exciting
is that, in addition to
the stream you get
as a player, there
is a second simultaneous stream
at 4K 60 frames per second
that you can choose
to share directly
to YouTube from the
Stadia data center,
meaning your gaming memories
will be saved at the highest
possible quality.
Stadia is not constrained
by the limitation
of traditional console systems.
Instead, we have built a truly
flexible, scalable, and modern
platform that allows us to push
performance beyond what was
previously considered possible.
This architecture gives us
even more flexibility to scale.
And thanks to fast transfer
speeds between the Stadia
instances in our data
center, our platform
can connect instances
together to dynamically expand
the capabilities along with
the need of your games.
As a developer, you're
used to being forced
to tone down your
creative ambitions that
are limited by the hardware,
but our vision with Stadia
is that the processing resources
available will scale up
to match your imagination.
In this new generation, the
data center is your platform.
We've partnered with our friends
at AMD to build a custom GPU.
I'd like to personally thank Dr.
Lisa Su, AMD president and CEO,
who is here with us today.
Lisa and her team
helped us design a chip
to bring you more than 10
teraflops of power, which we've
coupled with a custom CPU
to make up a single Stadia
instance.
And here's how the
graphical power of Stadia
compares to the top two
consoles in the market.
You can see--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You can see that a single Stadia
instance is a big step forward.
10.7 teraflops is more
powerful than the top two
consoles of the previous
generation combined.
[APPLAUSE]
Stadia will be using
the Linux operating
system and the open
graphics API Vulkan.
And when it comes
to game engines,
we are excited to announce
that we have partnered
with Unreal, who will be fully
supporting the Stadia platform.
We are also
partnering with Unity
to bring full support for the
two most popular and familiar
game engines to our
development community.
And we're empowering
developers was
an amazing array of
familiar middleware
that you already use
to power your game
development, including the most
popular physics engine, Havok.
And here's a list
of our partners now.
And of course, this list will
continue to grow over time.
With this suite of
tools, game development
can evolve as quickly inspires
the imagination of content
creators.
To achieve that, we're
providing multiple ways
to make games for Stadia.
You can develop on our cloud,
your cloud, and at your desk.
Our goal is to make Stadia
the most flexible development
environment ever put together.
And that power is, of course,
used to create the best
content.
Our first guest
is from a company
known for creating the most
sophisticated and impressive
gaming experiences
in the industry, that
always demand the most of
every system they run on.
We had the chance to give our
friends at id early access
to our tools and technology.
It's my absolute pleasure to
welcome to the stage executive
producer from id,
Marty Stratton.
[APPLAUSE]
MARTY STRATTON: Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for having
us here, Phil and Majd.
I'm honored to be
part of a team at id
that has spent more than
25 years on the bleeding
edge of technical innovation.
When we first met with Google
about game streaming, frankly,
we were skeptical,
about how it would work,
and in particular how it could
work with a game like "Doom."
However, we recognized not
just your ability and resources
to make game streaming a
reality, but more importantly,
the passion to support
a game as fast,
fluid, and
uncompromising as "Doom."
After all, if you're going
to prove to the world
that you can stream
games from the cloud,
what better proof than "Doom"?
And if you're going to
prove to a developer
that you're serious about
building a robust platform,
what better team than id,
where we push every platform
to its limit.
In fact, back in 2016,
"Doom" was the first AAA game
released on Vulkan.
And because Stadia is built
on that same Vulkan API,
it didn't take us
more than a few weeks
to get our upcoming sequel,
"Doom Eternal," looking
and playing great on Stadia
Built on the fun
and sense of power
players expect from the
series, "Doom Eternal"
is a pure and unfiltered
action FPS experience.
You play as an unstoppable hero
sent to destroy Hell's fiercest
demons across an
expanding universe
of unbelievable locations.
We couldn't be
happier to be bringing
"Doom Eternal" to
Stadia, and are
thrilled to announce that the
game will be capable of running
a true 4K resolution
with HDR color
at an unrelenting 60
frames per second.
[APPLAUSE]
We actually can't wait to show
you more of "Doom Eternal,"
very soon, in fact.
We have the full game
running on Stadia,
live from Google data centers,
and you can see it today
at our developer session.
It starts at 12:30
over in West Hall.
You won't want to miss it.
Thank you to Google
and Stadia team
for giving us this
opportunity to share
a bit about "Doom Eternal."
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL HARRISON: Thanks
so much, Marty.
It's a privilege to work with
id and your incredible engineers
and creators.
For anyone who
knows the franchise,
you know Doom Eternal will
look and play amazingly well
on our platform.
It was important
for us to partner
with a developer
like id, so that we
could prove, not
just to ourselves,
but to the entire industry
that our platform is
capable of supporting the
most demanding titles.
And Doom will be running
on a single Stadia GPU.
The fundamental benefit of our
cloud native infrastructure
is that developers
will be able to take
advantage of hardware and power
in ways never before possible.
And that includes
taking advantage
of the power of
multiple GPUs at once.
We've asked our friends at UL
Benchmarks, makers of 3DMark,
to put Stadia to the test.
In this video, you can
see some comparison points
showing the difference between
our single GPU and multiple
GPUs.
What you see here on
the left of the line
is running on a single
10.7 teraflop GPU.
And on the right
of the line, you
can see the same content running
on Stadia using multiple GPUs.
In this demo, we're highlighting
real time fluid defamation.
Accurate water simulation
is one of the most compute
intensive effects for games.
And it's a powerful example
of what Stadia is capable of,
and I'm so excited to see
where game developers go
with this kind of performance.
When we designed
Stadia, our goal
was to solve many
of the pain points
that we've heard about from
developers, particularly
those related to multiplayer.
In traditional platforms,
the client and server
are connected by the
unpredictable internet.
And therefore, the
multiplayer experience
is limited by the client with
the slowest or poorest quality
connection.
But with Stadia, that
game client and server
both remain on Google's
networking backbone,
resulting in predictable low
latency, reliable connectivity,
and data security,
since no traffic gets
exposed to the public internet.
Developers who use Google's
data centers can create
a predictable multiplayer
experience that scales
to an order of magnitude
greater than anything
enjoyed by gamers today.
What that means is
a synchronized state
across a very high volume of
players, where innovations
like distributed physics can
be built into your games, where
battle royale games could go
from hundreds of players today
to thousands of
players tomorrow.
And yes, no cheating
and no hacking.
Google has always
believed that the world
is a better place when
we are able to connect
without barriers.
And as a new generation
game platform,
Stadia will of course embrace
full cross-platform play.
[APPLAUSE]
Developers will have
the ability to enable
cross-platform multiplayer
for all players
and even bring games saves and
progression across as well.
I'd now like to introduce a
member of Stadia's R&D team
who are pushing the envelope,
bringing the best of Google
to game developers.
Please welcome to the
stage our lead designer
for research and development
at Stadia, Erin Hoffman-John.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIN HOFFMAN-JOHN:
Thank you, Phil.
One of our team's favorite
comments about Project Stream
was a tweet that describes
Stadia's technology
as the work of wizards.
And we are incredibly fortunate
to work with wizards every day,
bending their
magic toward games.
I'd like to take you through a
few technologies and features
that we've been working on that
are going to enhance the game
development process for
developers big and small.
The first one is
focused on multiplayer.
Stadia not only provides
high-performing multiplayer
experiences from
player to player,
but also allows developers to
create new, gorgeous gaming
environments.
Our friends at
Tangent Games have
been working with us on a
technical proof of concept
that you can see here behind me.
They spent a few
short weeks creating
this beautiful multiplayer world
with a persistent massively
destructible environment.
It is a raw demonstration
of scale and power
using the best of
Stadia technology, where
every piece of the environment
in this multiplayer world
is destructible using real
time, rigid body physics.
Using Google's unique
infrastructure,
developers can
create games built
to house hundreds of
players with low latency
and perfect synchronization.
This demo will be available
on the show floor,
if you want to check
it out this week.
As we were building
the platform,
we collaborated with
individual developers,
but we also thought about
trends in game development.
When we thought about our most
treasured gaming memories,
something kept coming back,
something that we'd lost.
When modern games start
to push the boundaries
of current hardware,
rendering two or more scenes
simultaneously becomes
too resource intensive.
And so split screen couch co-op
has been fading from gaming.
But when all of your
clients are in the cloud,
couch multiplayer has new
life again through Stadia,
in what we're calling
Stream Connect.
In the past, the
resources required
to execute split screen co-op
have required developers
to sacrifice more of
their creative goals.
With Stream Connect,
we're making
it possible to realize
split-screen multiplayer
without any performance penalty.
Behind me, you'll see a
technology proof of concept
that we built at Google.
It's called the Night
Forest, a co-op demo
with asymmetric player roles.
Here we have two players,
one hunter on the ground
and a supporting
aerial player, set up
in a standard split-screen view.
Each of these screens is powered
by a separate Stadia instance.
But what would happen
to squad-based games
if developers
could allow players
to call up the views of
their teammates on demand,
or utilize any polygonal
surface as a receiver
for another player's
video stream?
Stream Connect makes this
possible with extremely little
effort on the part
of the developer,
bringing dynamic squad-based
gaming into easy reach,
even for very small teams.
We've shown you three views,
but we can keep going.
We can keep adding streams
and shape how they're
shown to the player,
giving a designer not one,
but many cameras into a scene.
Now imagine if you
could go beyond seeing
into players' worlds.
What if you could
interact with them?
Here we have our
streams configured
into a command center,
where a fourth player
can coordinate the movements
of our drone, scientist,
and hunter characters.
Now that coordinator is
reaching into the world
and placing a beacon
to call attention
to a particular location, seen
instantly by the other players.
Stream connect is
just one of the ways
Google is working to
support developers
in creating more immersive
and creative experiences,
whether bringing back
effortless couch-based co-op
or inventing entirely
new multiplayer games.
Our next technology demo focuses
on the power of the Google
cloud and machine
learning, and how
they can have an impact
on accelerating developer
creativity.
Every developer feels the
burn in pre-production
to get to a game's magic sooner.
We think Google's machine
learning technology
might have some answers.
Here to talk about it
is a developer known
for creating some amazing,
stylish, and celebrated
independent games, including
"Deadlight," "Rime,"
and "The Invisible Hours."
Please welcome chairwoman of
Tequila Works, Luz Sancho.
[APPLAUSE]
LUZ SANCHO: Thank you, Erin.
I am very excited to be here
for the unveiling of the Stadia
platform.
There are so many
different benefits
that the Stadia delivers to
all developers, big and small,
and particularly for
a studio like ours.
At Tequila Works, we are
very proud of the artist
styles of our games.
It's something we spend
a lot of time perfecting.
Our development cycles
typically last 24 months.
And as you can imagine,
a large part of that time
is dedicated to defining the
artist style of the game.
We are particularly
proud of "Rime."
It's visual identity
created a lasting impression
with our players.
But it took us a long time
to get to that final style.
That's why we were so excited
to hear from Google about one
of the tools they
are making available,
an amazing tool that will
dramatically influence and ease
this process.
With Style Transfer
ML, Google is
applying the science of machine
learning to art visualization.
ERIN HOFFMAN-JOHN:
Style Transfer
is a machine learning
technology that
runs on the video frame
created by the game.
All of this happens in real
time on a Stadia instance.
We built this demo to
show you what it can do.
We start with a gray box world
and take any image we want,
in this case, Kandinsky's
"Yellow, Red, Blue,"
and the model does the rest.
Throw it "Starry Night,"
and you have another style.
Give it scratch art,
and you get this.
We're doing our part
to empower the artist
inside of every developer.
The R&D team iterated through
hundreds of art styles,
testing this technology.
And one of our favorites
came from an old friend.
[APPLAUSE]
What excites us and some of
our partners so far is how many
playable art styles we can
create just by feeding it
more and more images.
It inspires and
empowers our artists
to get the visions
in their heads
into interactive environments
in a whole new way.
And this is just the beginning.
LUZ SANCHO: We are using Style
Transfer ML in our studio
today, and we are blown
away by the impact it's
having on our latest creations.
You will see it.
This could really
change everything.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIN HOFFMAN-JOHN:
Thank you, Luz.
What Style Transfer,
our goal is to help
developers find the magic
of their games quicker.
You can check out Style Transfer
during the show this week.
We can't wait to
hear your feedback.
Creators inspire us to bring
the best of Google to games,
and creators are at
the heart of Stadia.
It isn't just what they create,
but how those moments are
experienced by players, moments
that resonate for generations
to come.
The last feature we
want to introduce today
is another special experience
made possible by the cloud.
It's called State Share.
And here to talk about it from
Q Games is Dillon Cuthbert.
[APPLAUSE]
DYLAN CUTHBERT: Hey, everyone.
It's great to be here
with all of you today.
As a veteran game developer,
I love how creators on YouTube
have brought our games to life.
But I've always wished
those experiences could be
more social and even more fun.
I'm extremely excited
about what I've
learned from Google about
bringing new ways to share
a game's replayable moments.
With a new technology
called State Share,
developers can let a
player instantly share
a playable moment from a game.
This could include the world
state, the player's position,
items they're carrying, anything
the developer wants to pack
into a shareable moment.
The game state can be encoded
into a link that tells Stadia
where to pick up the game.
This could be sent
to one player,
or it could be
shared with thousands
at the same time on YouTube,
through email, apps, messaging,
or wherever links can go.
To me, this totally
changes how I
think about the
experiences for players.
I can create
moments specifically
for this kind of
sharing, challenges
to beat my incredible
speed runs,
or chances for other
players to also experience
those same tough boss battles.
I can build as many
sharable moments as I want,
and let the internet turn my
whole game into an infinitely
replaceable treasure hunt.
I was so intrigued with the
possibilities of State Share
that I designed a brand
new game around it,
and it's the biggest
title ever for Q Games.
Right now, it's
still under WRAPS
but I can't wait to reveal
more about this game
later this year.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIN HOFFMAN-JOHN:
Thanks, Dylan.
State Share is one
more way that Stadia
is working to empower developers
with entirely new tools that
embrace a player's desire to
discover, share, and build
a community.
We're extremely excited by
the reception it's gotten
from our early partners so far.
And with that, I'd like to
introduce the head of gaming
at YouTube to tell
you what Stadia
means for content creators.
Please welcome Ryan Wyatt.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN WYATT: Thanks, Erin.
I'm very excited to be here
at the unveiling of Stadia.
As you've heard, Stadia is about
delivering the best developer
experience so that the
best games can be made.
But we're also
committed to making sure
we have the best
creator experience,
so that the entire community
gets stronger together.
YouTube is where people
come to watch gaming.
More than 200
million gamers come
to YouTube every
single day to engage
with their favorite
games and creators.
And they come because of the
community of gaming creators
and viewers who have turned
YouTube into the gaming
platform that it is today.
We're always looking
for ways to strengthen
the connection between
creators and viewers,
and Stadia is designed to
bring them together like never
before.
Gaming has always been
the backbone of YouTube
since the platform first
was founded in 2005.
And one thing YouTube
gaming creators want
is to engage with their fans.
That will always be the most
important thing to them.
That's why over 50 billion
hours of gaming content
was watched on YouTube
last year alone.
And to just give you an idea of
how much 50 billion hours is,
you could walk to Pluto and
back more than a dozen times.
Stadia's focused on empowering
both creators and viewers
to achieve new heights by
breaking barriers of content
capture and creating unique
ways to engage with and grow
a creator's audience.
Established creators will have
new ways to engage and monetize
on YouTube with Stadia features.
And with aspiring
creators, we're
going to break down the barrier
of entry in capturing content
by giving you the
ability to highlight,
live stream, and capture
directly from Stadia.
We've already seen the
idea of any YouTube link
being a direct access
point into the game,
and that is a huge
opportunity for
both big and small creators.
We're empowering creators
to forge deeper connections
with their audience.
And one of those ways
will be to make it easier
to actually game with them.
Often when you're
watching a stream,
you find yourself
wishing you could
be in there, playing alongside
with your favorite creators.
On traditional
platforms, you'd have
to fire up your
console or your PC,
and just hope that you
get matched up with them.
However, with Stadia and a
new feature called Crowd Play,
you'll be able to simply click
a button, displayed right
in the stream, and jump in
and play with YouTube creators
that you're watching.
Take a look at the
video behind me.
It's a live stream of NBA 2K.
The person watching can
simply click the link
and be placed into the
lobby for the next game.
If you think about
it, Crowd Play
can act like an all-new
lobby system for games.
And with Stadia, YouTube
becomes the ultimate discovery
and engagement tool for content.
And of course, YouTube creators
will have full management
capabilities over this feature.
To all of the game
developers, publishers,
and the millions of YouTube
content creators out there,
soon we'll have more
information to share
on these engagement
tools and how
we'll be working with you
to connect with and build
your communities.
I'd now like to introduce a
friend of mine to the stage.
He has over 11 million
subscribers on his channel
the Game Theorist,
and he and his wife
Stephanie have often been
advocates for the creator
community.
So we were delighted to
talk to him about Stadia
and what it means
for Creators please
welcome to the stage
my friend, MatPat.
MATPAT: Thanks, Ryan.
It's an incredible
honor to be here today.
Now, for us creators, our
audience is our lifeblood.
Whether we're breaking
down the real life
science of the fictional
world of Fallout,
or diving into the
theories behind Bendy
and the Ink Machine, or
simply streaming gameplay
on our live stream
channel, GT Live,
we're always
looking for new ways
to connect and engage
with our audience.
Which is why when I first
met with the Stadia team,
I was floored by the impact
that it can have for not just
gamers but also creators.
Stadia not only empowers me
to easily create and share
my work, but it also unlocks
completely new ways for me
to build a stronger
bond with my audience.
Crowd play, for example,
gives our audiences the chance
to instantly jump
into a game with us,
and then the creator
can feature them live
on the stream in real time.
Another feature that I'm
incredibly excited about
is State Share.
Here, the possibilities
are literally endless.
Live streaming horror
games, for instance,
has been one of the most popular
formats for live streaming
on YouTube since its inception.
But now with State
Share, you can actually
take this to the next level
by letting the people who
were just watching you replicate
the exact same scenario you
just played through in-game.
Like that impossible moment
when you're out of med kits
and you suddenly have a zombie
breathing down your neck,
imagine the endless
variations that creators
can layer on top of all
their favorite games
by specifically designing
challenges oriented
to their unique audience.
For creators, you suddenly
become a game maker yourself.
Creating challenges
through State Share
allows us to continue creating
content for all your favorite
games long after the game
itself has been completed.
And on the other
hand, the audience
now can reconnect with all their
favorite games in completely
new, exciting, and fresh ways.
But of course, also
as a gamer, I'm
looking forward
to, tremendously,
all the new possibilities of
gameplay that Stadia opens up
and that can be built
only for Stadia.
I mean, think about this.
1,000 player battle
royale matches, incredible
new graphical possibilities.
And of course, all of this is
available across any screen.
Literally, I could
just pick up my phone
and start playing exactly
where I left off on my laptop,
even while sitting
in an audience
of a keynote like this one.
I hope you're not
playing right now.
A lot of exciting stuff
happening on stage.
But you could do it!
Stadia just truly
unlocks new opportunities
to create, share, and
engage across YouTube.
I am personally
thrilled about what
Stadia brings to the table,
how it unites technology
and entertainment in
completely new ways
that we have never seen before,
and in ways that can only
be possible through the combined
power of Google and YouTube.
So I thank the Stadia team
for having me in here today.
I can't wait to see what
else you guys have in store,
and I'll see the rest of
you on the floors of GDC.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL HARRISON: Thanks
Ryan and MatPat.
Connecting players and creators
to their favorite games
is core to our vision.
We've shown you how
YouTube and Stadia offer
the ability for gamers to
connect with content creators
and game developers
in extraordinary ways.
There is another Stadia
integration with YouTube
that we're really excited about.
Designers love
creating challenge,
but as games reach
more and more people,
the design problem of
creating a perfect challenge
gets more and more difficult.
When a player is stuck
on a level or puzzle
and desperately wants that
next beat in the story
or the breathtaking views in
the next level, what do they do?
Today, they have
to leave the game,
fire up YouTube,
find the right video,
scrub to the right part of that
video, and watch how it's done.
With Stadia, that help will
be just a button press away.
Take this example
from our friends
at Crystal Dynamics with
the Rise of the Tomb Raider.
When the player gets
stuck on a level,
like me, instead of grabbing
a laptop or a phone,
they just need to push the
button on the Stadia controller
to get help from the
Google Assistant.
No distractions, no need to
take your eyes off the game,
and no secondary devices needed.
[APPLAUSE]
It's another deep way in
which we're connecting players
with the games they love.
Stadia is about removing
barriers for players
to get to their favorite
content and moments.
With Stadia, any link can be
an access point to the game.
So for a developer, the entire
internet can become your Store
whether it's from our Stadia
Store, text messages, Reddit,
Facebook, Twitter, Discord,
Google search results, YouTube
videos, Gmail, or from
the Google Play Store,
gamers are going to be able
to find, discover, and enjoy
your games anywhere
they are and easily
share them with their friends.
It's a truly revolutionary
way to discover your games.
Stadia will be home
to a variety of games,
and we're happy to
say that we will
offer comprehensive parental
controls for all content.
We've already shipped
development hardware
to more than 100 studios
around the world,
and more than 1,000
creatives and engineers
are hard at work bringing
their games to our platform.
In addition to partnering
with developers big and small,
I'm also thrilled to
announce that today we
are forming Stadia Games
and Entertainment, which
will build experiences
designed exclusively
for Stadia as Google's own
first party game studio.
[APPLAUSE]
And we've recently been joined
by one of the industry's
most successful
executive producers
to lead that organization.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome
the new head of Stadia Games
and Entertainment, Jade Raymond.
[APPLAUSE]
JADE RAYMOND: Thank you, Phil.
Thank you, everyone.
I am so honored to be here
at the unveiling of Stadia.
In my career, I've
been lucky enough
to work with some of the
most talented and passionate
developers in the world.
Passion is at the root
of all great games.
And it's what motivated
me to join Google.
What I love about games
is that we continue
to redefine what a game is.
When I was 12, I
saw the holodeck
on an episode of Star Trek.
And even though the games
I played at the time
were side-scrolling pixel-based
kind of games like "Mega Man,"
it was obvious to me that one
day games would take place
in fully immersive worlds.
Today, you have seen
some incredible tech.
And hopefully, like
me, you now believe
that we are on the brink of
a huge revolution in gaming,
one that will unlock a whole
new level of creativity
for developers.
There are no limits to
the human imagination.
Now that the data
center is your platform,
the processing power
is limitless as well.
I'm excited to announce that
as the head of Stadia Games
and Entertainment, I will not
only be bringing first party
games studios to re-imagine
the new generation of games,
our team will also be working
with external developers
to make all of the bleeding
edge Google technology you've
seen here today available to
partner studios big and small.
We are committed--
[APPLAUSE]
To going down the bold path,
learning what is working best,
and sharing key tools and
tech, so that we can take games
to the next level together.
The way I see it, there has
never been a more exciting time
to be a developer, and Stadia
will be a driving force,
defining the future of
games and entertainment.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL HARRISON: Thank you,
Jade, and a very warm welcome
to Google.
With Stadia, our
goal is to combine
the world of people who play
games and the world of people
who watch games into one
global community, powered
by the best of Google.
We've shared a lot today.
With Stadia, you'll be able
to build your games backed
by Google technology,
like Google Assistant, ML,
and TensorFlow.
You will be able to
deliver your games
to more gamers across the globe
through Chrome, Chromecast,
and Pixel.
And you'll be able to
connect with the biggest
community of gamers and
YouTube content creators.
So how do you get involved?
For developers who want to
create content for Stadia,
we welcome you to
go to stadia.dev,
where you can apply to get
access to development tools.
If you want to partner
with our team at Google
to help bring your
game to market,
we have Stadia Partners,
a program designed
to give you the
resources your team needs
to make something great.
And for players who want to
be the first to learn more,
you can go to
stadia.com and follow us
on these social channels.
So when will players be
able to experience Stadia?
I'm thrilled to
announce that Stadia
is launching this year, 2019.
[APPLAUSE]
We will launch first
in the US, Canada,
the UK, and most of Europe.
It's been my privilege today
to introduce Stadia on behalf
of the thousands of Googlers
who've worked tirelessly
to bring this vision to life.
This is the first
step in the journey,
and we'll be connecting
with you again
in the summer to share more
details on the games you'll get
to play at launch and beyond.
Thank you very much for
gathering around with all of us
today.
With Stadia, we can all
dream bigger, and together
build a playground
for every imagination.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]